my heroes are always people who feel
themselves to be set apart stigmatized
or a bird that's at the heart of most of
my night it's certainly on the heart of
this movie
fantastic beasts and where to find them
was a textbook that Harry Potter used at
school while I was writing Potter I
became quite interested in nooks
commander so I knew quite a lot about
nude he's been traveling the world
studying magical creatures because
himself a Magister ologist first trip to
America yes
let's get that fixed nudes creatures
blows in this magical case you open it
up you can go down it's an amazing space
it feels more at home with creatures
that he does with human being come on
give me as far
Newt walks into a society he doesn't
really understand this is gonna do you
know anything about the Wizarding
community in America I know that you
have rather backwards towards about
relations with no magic people you don't
mean to befriend them you can't marry
them which seems wildly of City marry
him and then Jacob accidentally opens in
its case full of magical creatures hey
mr. English guy I think your egg is
hatching some new tickets embroiled in
this adventure he saw little bit more
like a pair
it's something that has implications for
the whole wizard your world
didn't you see man let's just come
handle just like your suitcase I think
there's much more to you than meets the
eye